here's a mystery for you climate change
is a major global threat but not yet a
major topic of kitchen table
conversation and in fact that may be the
biggest threat of all according to a new
book it's called saving us a climate
scientist case for hope and healing in a
divided world it's published by an
imprint of simon schuster which is a
division of viacom cbs the scientist's
name is catherine heiho she's the author
and she points out that more than half
of the u.s adults are concerned about
climate change but only a third of us
ever talk about it
she says her goal is to change that
you might think all this extreme weather
fueled by runaway global warming
accompanied by endless warnings from
scientists and activists how dare you
celebrities and world leaders we have
reached the tipping point on the need
for climate action is also a big talker
for people at home
but how
often do you talk about climate change
have we once talked about maybe once or
twice in our you know seven year
relationship on a recent day at the
dallas world aquarium we found most
people just don't usually get into it
have you ever in your life
started a conversation intentionally
with someone else about the issue of
climate change i'll be honest i probably
have it
the question of course is why if climate
change threatens all of us shouldn't all
of us be talking about it most people
are worried about this catherine heiho
is a prominent you might even say famous
climatologist at texas tech university
who studies not only the climate but the
conversation around it i mean if one
more person tells you about a starving
polar bear or a melting iceberg or
rising sea levels you're just like what
am i supposed to do i'm just one person
i'm not like the president or ceo or
anything what you're supposed to do hey
ho argues the most important thing any
of us can do
is the one thing so many of us have been
avoiding
we have to talk about it you think
regular people
can start a revolution on this by having
conversations in their community
i think that's the only way a revolution
has ever started to see how she does it
without devolving into politics or
argument we started some conversations
of our own for me i feel like this world
ain't going to survive long all right
well i just want to bring in katherine
right now and then we asked hey ho to
take over did you know that 90 companies
are responsible for two-thirds of the
whole global warming problem since the
beginning of the industrial era i did
not know that we noticed that while
heiho was often full of facts you know
how many people die every year because
of air pollution
almost nine million really her first
move wasn't to lecture but to listen we
see changes in weather patterns but they
don't happen as close to home when she
did jump in it wasn't with global data
but local issues here's the thing if we
live in texas we're getting hit hardest
of any state
the hurricanes the floods the heat even
the crazy winter storm that we had it
was worse because of the arctic warming
so fast right here in irvine you know
the rangers they had to build them a new
stadium that they could close the roof
on to air condition it because it was
too hot for people to play in it and in
conversation after conversation heiho
kept the focus on solutions
texas is number one in wind energy
we're number one reminding people that
while the challenges may seem
overwhelming from my perspective it
doesn't seem like much you know regular
humans can really do about it america
does have a pretty good track record of
getting it right eventually you know 150
years ago a woman couldn't vote
and then you know like 70 years ago
there was civil rights
and all of that changed and how did it
change it changed because people that's
true started talking about it
and they started saying this is not fair
this is not the way the world should be
the world has to be different and
speaking of different we started this
conversation with you telling me that
the world was essentially doomed yeah it
pretty much is
what's the next what's the first step to
getting together
talking about it
has this conversation
changed you in any way
yeah i mean i would i'd be more vocal to
it
i'd want to spread the awareness no no
you
[Applause]
there's one
so so catherine has actually had a lot
more than one like she she travels the
country and has given thousands of
lectures and had thousands of
conversations with people about climate
change and and wakes people up to the
issue and actually what i love about the
book is it's kind of a user's guide to
help other people go and do the very
same thing although i also have to say
in my experience when i started talking
about climate change at home that's what
my wife's like
or you know that's when the friends are
over but normally people's eyes do do
glaze yeah if you've got friends over at
dinner and you bring it up they're like
oh we got a long drive yeah we better
hit the road well people do see it as a
buzz kill until it sinks in that we're
killing the earth but that's a buzz kill
it's hard to talk about this with with
the appropriate degree of of
measuredness but also urgency yeah but i
liked how she does it though tony i like
how she puts it in very um edible
concrete facts
that we can all pay attention to nine
million people die of air pollution
that's a that's yeah and by the way the
reason for that matters is because
the political solution a system change
is the only way to do this all of us
recycling and putting solar panels on a
roof that doesn't add up to enough
i like that khaki shirt you were rocking
thank you my animal show coming out soon
it's in development now looks good tony
the tigers coming soon more to come this
is cbs mornings we'll be right back